die ard möchte ostdeutsche rentner die
durch die überleitung benachteiligung
erlitten haben lediglich mit einer
lösung auf hartz-iv-niveau allein ob die
doppelbesteuerung
durchaus trennen der
ddr geschiedene haben sie überhaupt
keine lösung fremden versicherung
pflegeversicherung das sind die
kostentreiber der zukunft
krankenversicherung die werden steigen
jede partei die steuererleichterung
verspricht die lügt
[Musik]
wir wollen gleich über über löhne
sprechen ist das auch für sie ein thema
also gleiche bezahlung im vergleich ost
und west also mit löhnen schuster bleib
bei deinem leisten ich muss mich der
dame anschließend man braucht mut sich
selbstständig zu machen und ich bin seit
zwölf jahren selbstständig ich bin
allein ich habe keinen echten vergleich
in den löhnen ich kann mich auf das
berufen was zum beispiel eine gute
bekannte die
gleichstellungsbeauftragte ist mir
erzählt aber ich habe keine praktische
bewegung und das wirklich an der stelle
sagen über löhne und ungleichheit habe
ich nur gehört kann ich nichts wirklich
echte star vielleicht erfahren sie heute
noch ein bisschen was darüber dann ja
erstmal zu dir von constanze buch in dem
er auch gerade im film schon gesehen
haben erstmal ein schirm guten abenteuer
das sie zu uns gekommen sind
[Musik]
dass jemand ein gedicht in unserer
sendung rezitiert hatten wir auch noch
nicht für alles ist es immer eine
premiere es auch schön
wie schätzen sie das mit dem thema löhne
ein sagen sie ich gucke erst mal auf
mich oder ich guck erstmal auf die
anderen oder ich zeige mit dem finger
dahin und damit meine ich dann auf die
politik also ich würde mich ein wenig an
schließen den den punkten die du schon
gebracht hast mir wenn wir die fragen
stellen die wir also du sie meinen sie
sie haben sich nie kennengelernt
entschuldigung in der alles gut das wir
stellen die falschen fragen meines
erachtens und wir schauen auf die
falschen stellen und prägen damit eine
bestimmte haltung die wir künstlich am
leben erhalten
eben die löhne die die lohn debatten
sind rein unternehmens debatten und ich
würde ganz gerne auch einmal an der
stelle den fokus auf das
selbstbewusstsein tatsächlich lenken
denn ich glaube tatsächlich dass wir das
die lücke die wir sehen eine
selbstbewusstseins lücke ist und dass
die entstanden ist in der wende das ist
zweifelsohne nachvollziehbar und wir
können jetzt sozusagen den schwarzen
peter die kann die ganze zeit in
richtung der der unternehmen schieben
wir können aber eben auch sagen was
können wir dazu beitragen dass menschen
selbstbewusster werden in dieser region
dann auch besser zu verhandeln um dann
anders aufzutreten um selbst zu wissen
sich selbst darüber bewusst zu sein was
kann ich was trage ich bei und was ist
mein wert und wenn wir dieses
selbstbewusstsein tatsächlich auch
medial in den fokus stellen dann werden
wir eine ganz andere haltung produzieren
und werden positive rollenvorbilder
tatsächlich produzieren und damit auch
stolz das ist ein toller und auch
wichtiger punkt und dennoch ist es und
ich trage das jetzt was sie gesagt haben
mit zurück in die runde dennoch sind die
lebensverhältnisse auch wenn viel
passiert ist immer noch unterschiedlich
und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe
geht es um selbstbewusstsein um respekt
und gute arbeit gehört dann natürlich
dazu frau kipping über die löhne haben
wir
sprachen sprechen wir über den
niedriglohnbereich jeder dritte
ostdeutsche jede dritte ostdeutsche
beschäftigte arbeitet im
niedriglohnbereich was wollen sie
dagegen tun wir als linke waren die
ersten die druck gemacht haben finden
mindestlohn der ist meine schlimmste im
aufgefangen hat der muss jetzt noch
deutlich erhöht werden und man muss
sagen im ost nicht nur
niedriglohnbereich generell der
durchschnittslohn im osten liegt bei
knapp über 80 prozent vom westdeutschen
durchschnitt das heißt da haben wir was
zu tun und manchmal merken dass
beschäftigte die übrigens ein
zunehmendes selbstbewusstsein haben und
es entwickeln die vor allen dingen dann
wenn die gemeinsam für das einstehen was
ihnen zusteht nämlich ordentliche löhne
ich fast vor kurzem beiden riesa nudeln
dann gibt es halt ein
produktionsstandort in riesa und dann
ein im westen und die sagen halt der
gehaltsunterschied liegt bei über 700
euro im monat und die wollen jetzt ein
einstieg in die lohnangleichung die
unterstützen wir mit allem was man
öffentlichkeit hat und zu weinen aber
auch dazu sagen die linke regiert ja
schon seit einigen jahren in thüringen
und auch da sieht es im
niedriglohnsektor
ja da hast du mein wissen doch dass der
mindestlohn ist doch eine frage die auf
bundesebene entschieden werden muss in
der bundesregierung waren wir bisher
nicht ich bin wild entschlossen das zu
ändern unter anderem weil man nur auf
bundesebene was tun dann gegen niedrige
löhne für gute arbeit und ich will noch
mal sagen weil sie so gegen die
niedrigen löhne geschimpft haben muss
ich dann doch in erinnerung rufen dass
ihre partei heftig gegen die stärkung
der flächentarifverträge im bundestag
gewettet hat kann man nachlesen im
plenarprotokoll dabei sind gerade die
wichtig also es braucht ein
zusammenspiel von guten gesetzlichen
mindeststandards dafür machen wir druck
wir waren die ersten mussten nach und
nach alle überzeugen und es braucht
natürlich entsprechend starke
betriebsräte und tarifverträge das gute
ist die beschäftigten über als und
verschiedensten orten werden da
kämpferisch und das ist für mich auch
ein quell von optimismus dass wir zu
gleichen lebensverhältnisse kommen eine
wichtige voraussetzung um die einheit zu
vollenden beim ig bau hat das glaube ich
ganz gut funktioniert daran kann sich ja
der eine oder andere vielleicht noch ein
beispiel herr pofalla im wahlprogramm
der linken gibt es ein sehr
ausführliches kapitel zum thema der
osten den osten sternen bei ihnen bei
der afg findet man im wahlprogramm so
gut wie gar auch nichts außer zum thema
renten die sowieso ab 2025 angeglichen
werden was tun sie konkret für die
menschen im osten des landes er zum
einen sehen wir erst mal gesamtdeutsche
partei von daher müssen wir den osten
nicht explizit herausnehmen und so im
wahlprogramm gerade die zahlen gehen sie
haben selber löhne auf die schweizer von
ping eingehen wenn man vom guten löhnen
spricht auch von mindestlöhnen übrigens
hat der mindestlohn auch die mindestlohn
einführung auch arbeitsplatzverlust
dabei geführt dass wissen sie gar nicht
geschafft das wissen sie ganz genau dass
industrie und gewinne muss man sich auch
leisten können ich bin ja selbst
unternehmer handwerksmeister ich würde
meinen gesellen und hätte meinen gesehen
sehr gern 23 euro mehr gehen natürlich
gerne aber ich brauch die auftraggeber
die das zahlen können also die
bevölkerung muss auch das leisten können
also wir brauchen natürlich eine
industrie und auch einen mittelstand der
in deutschland erhalten ostdeutschland
erhalten bleibt unter der wird ja
weiterhin abgebaut zum beispiel auch
durch die klimawende durch die energie
ausstieg die grünen und die linken
natürlich mit befürworten auch sie den
kohleausstieg wollen sie noch
beschleunigen frau kipping damit
schaffen sie genau die guten bezahlten
arbeitsplätze noch ab also sie befördern
sogar noch weiterhin die spirale nach
unten und genau das ist was die iaaf die
nicht möchte wir möchten einen behutsam
ausstieg daraus vor allem brauchen wir
auch eine grundlastfähige
energieversorgung damit auch die bürger
und das ist der nächste punkt sich strom
in zukunft auch noch leisten können in
beiden teilen deutschlands also wir
machen uns stark für eine
beschäftigungsgarantie für alle die im
kohleabbau tier wurde an die das
arbeiten wurde das setzen uns dafür ein
dass die gelder die den strukturwandel
eingeplant werden dass die auch in der
region bleiben und nicht irgendwie
abgehen und muss noch mitnahme effekte
gibt für konzerne sie hatten ja so ein
bisschen zum beispiel mal genannt aber
ich muss ein satz zum thema rente sagen
weil das der einzige punkt der im
fdp-wahlprogramm überhaupt zum osten
vorkommt und da geht es aber nur um ein
härtefallfonds das heißt es muss man
noch mal übersetzen die ard möchte
ostdeutsche rentner die durch die
überleitung benachteiligung erlitten
haben lediglich mit einer lösung auf
hartz-iv-niveau allein ob die
doppelbesteuerung
der
ddr geschiedene haben sie überhaupt
keine lösung für pflegende angehörige
haben sie keine lösung für welche gibt
ganz viele berufsgruppen die
benachteiligt worden sind und da sagt
ihr war ganz klar die sind uns ziemlich
egal so weit zurück was ist eine
ostdeutsche partei herr krupp aller
lassen sie uns und das ist ein wichtiges
thema haben wir bei für und wieder
einmal ganz ausführlich darüber
gesprochen nämlich steuern sie haben ein
steuerkonzept und da gibt es ein
rechenbeispiel ein alleinverdiener eine
alleinverdienende wie auch immer eine
familie mit zwei kindern einkommen
40.000 euro die sollen entlastet werden
nach ihrem steuerkonzept und zwar um
sage und schreibe 21 euro wenn man über
300.000 euro verdient dann wird man ein
klassisches hatten sie schon in der ard
gebracht
unsere zuschauer zuschauerin zu hause
haben dürfen sie mich gerne korrigieren
ab 300.000 gibt es eine entlastung bzw
mehr und zwar in höhe von 42.000
versiert sagen das sei falsch es ist vom
renommierten
wirtschaftsforschungsinstituts rtw nicht
von mir wollen wir jetzt extrem
auseinander wie bringen jetzt hier
zahlen müssten sie genau die
steuerklassen aufzählen wir müssen sie
die freibeträge auf denen das können sie
jetzt nicht das kann ich genauso wenig
also von da sie wirken wir haben dieses
bereits nachgewiesen dass dieses
beispiel was im übrigen auch der kollege
da ist im ard gemacht hat falsch ist
dass zum 1 zum anderen will ich ihnen
sagen wir reden immer von
steuerentlastungen gerade bei niedrigen
und kleinen einkommen wer wenig steuern
in deutschland zahlt der kann auch kaum
noch steuerlich entlastet werden es muss
man als grundlage das muss man also wenn
ihr mal die 100.000 euro am ende der
seit 2000 das erreicht was jedoch
tatsachen das ist einfach fair news was
jetzt hier also das ist eine falsche
zahl die es hier bringen wir also das
zww liegt ich da eigentlich auf der
rechten
ich weiß doch gar nicht welche
rechengrundlage steuerfreibeträge kinder
etc da dieses als grundlage genommen sie
schmeißen jetzt hier eine einen saal
hinein die nicht nachweisbar und
apple ich will
ganz klar
wir reden immer nur von steuerbefreiung
wir sollten mal über die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge das ist ein
prinzip der kostentreiber in deutschland
rentenversicherung pflegeversicherung
das sind die kostentreiber der zukunft
krankenversicherung die werden steigen
jede partei die steuererleichterung
verspricht die lügt es wird keine
steuererleichterung geben wenn dann
fangen sie an mit der co2 steuer
schaffen sie die endlich ab denn das ist
der kostentreiber mittelstand handwerk
und auch für die frage ist ein bisschen
durcheinander
für alle die sich jetzt fragen wer recht
hat man kann ja selber nachlesen ich
habe die studie des diw auch noch einmal
im heute in vorbereitung auf die sendung
mit durchgelesen ich fand die tabellen
sehr plausibel kann sich ja jeder selber
eine meinung bilden vor allen dingen ist
auf grundlage dieser berechnung des zds
haben wir uns mal angeschaut wie sich
die unterschiedlichen steuerprogramm und
wahlprogramme der parteien auf die
sozialen unterschiede auswirken und
diese grafik ich werde auch dann noch
mal bei mir rein stellen kommt zu dem
klaren ergebnis die linken vorschläge
führen dazu dass die soziale
ungleichheit deutlich abnimmt wird um
bei cdu bei fdp und ganz besonders bei
der ard wird die soziale ungleichheit
deutlich zunehmen das heißt ihre
behauptung sie wären der anti
establishment partei stimmt leider nicht
sie sind inzwischen die partei des
großen geldes das wundert mich auch
nicht denn sie nimmt gerne spenden an
von immobilienkonzern gsw
immobilien lobby bekommen also und da
also dass sie ich glaube und sie ein
wohnung habe ich habe zwei sachen wir
sollten die steuer diskussion noch mal
nachlesen gleich nach der sendung und
dann werden wir also wäre senken wenn
wir sehen wir recht haben wer recht hat
zweitens wollten wir sagen
wirtschaftlich wir haben jetzt die
negativen punkte angesprochen ist auch
viel passiert in diesen 30 jahren in der
wirtschaft in der infrastruktur wollen
jetzt aber über ein thema sprechen wo
noch nicht so viel passiert ist und da
muss man wirklich sagen die zahlen sind
wirklich niederschmetternd ich glaube
für jeden der aus dem osten des landes
kommt unserer geht es um führungs und
spitzenpositionen
da haben es gerade mal zwei bis drei
prozent in solche positionen geschafft
wie kann das sein fragt man sich nach
über 30 jahren frau kipping an mich
vielleicht an was aber an wem liegt das
denn
ja ich glaube das hat ein bisschen was
am anfang mit 90er jahren zu tun auch
mit der treuhand politik und damit das
haben ja viele erlebt damals dass die
veränderungen sich eher fremd bestimmt
über sie hinweg stattgefunden haben und
dann gibt so ein effekt das halt ganz
manche erlitten dann sehr eine
geschlossene gesellschaft sind und ich
glaube um darunter dagegen also es gibt
natürlich auch deutsche die haben es
geschafft ein paar sitzen ja hier aber
ich glaube die mussten deutlich ist ein
bisschen wie mir der frack mit frau und
die mussten deutlich mehr einsatz zeigen
als das vielleicht andere mussten was
kann man jetzt dagegen tun gut wäre ja
wenn zb der ostbeauftragte nicht nur
problemberichte schreibt sondern sich
auch noch mal stärken im ziel
verpflichtet nämlich einfach die klugen
und exzellenten köpfe die es im osten
gibt zu fördern zu vernetzen da kann man
sich an den instrumenten der
frauenförderung orientieren also da ein
bisschen rücken genauso geben für die
klugen köpfe im osten her thronicke hat
gerade laut geklatscht weil er ja eben
auch schon die politischen eliten
angesprochen hat und wir haben hier ein
paar zahlen die abteilungsleiter in
bundesministerien
da gibt es gerade vier ostdeutsche von
133 positionen und es gibt auch keine
ost minister in der bundesregierung
die kanzlerin ist aus dem osten europas
es gab von den linken 2009 10 einen
antrag im bundestag für eine ost quote
in bundesbehörden der hat die afd nicht
dafür gestimmt warum nicht ja weil wir
generell quoten bildung ablehnen deshalb
ist genau das gleiche mit der
frauenquote also wenn dann muss ich
schon die qualität auch durchsetzen
wenngleich ich ihnen durchaus recht gebe
ich wünsche mir auch mehr das aus
deutschland wünschen reiche nicht wenn
sie gar mit einer quote mit einer
kleinen quote wollen wir wollen sie es
denn verändern damit einer quote regeln
sie gar nichts das ist zwang mit quote
kamera somit dann wurde kann man
natürlich eine rede ist ja das könnte
ein übergang sein um dann eine
veränderung zu schaffen sie müssen doch
konstatieren dass es in 30 jahren nicht
gelungen ist mehr ostdeutsche in diese
führungsposition sei es in der politik
oder in der wirtschaft zu bringen da
müssen sie doch als politiker sagen das
müssen wir ändern ich frage sie wollen
sie ist jetzt müssen wir ändern nehmen
wir die leute natürlich auch mut machen
und dem auch im prinzip der mumm fehlt
doch vielen ostdeutschen genau diese
position ostdeutschen sind schuld ich
habe mich gesagt die schuld sind es
fehlt vielen ostdeutschen durchaus doch
der muss sich für diese position einer
zu bewerben und auch die sich dieser
verantwortung zu stellen und das geben
wir lesen das
ist ja richtig aber trotzdem wollen uns
ja viele nicht mache ich kenne beispiele
aus eigener erfahrung wo sich aus
deutschland zurück gesagt herr krupp
einmal ein bis drei prozent so viele
das können sie doch nicht mit einer
quote regeln wie wollen sie das denn
machen also quotenregelung sind schon
immer gescheitert in allen bereichen bei
der frauenquote könnte das aber ich habe
noch mal fragen also ich höre sie sagen
die ostdeutschen sind schuld weil sie
nicht nötig gehabt hätten das werden ja
ich habe sie sind aber nicht die schuld
konfrontieren dass der ford jena klar
mit schuld dann sagen woran hätte sie
sagen die ostdeutschen haben keinen mumm
ich frage sie und ich habe noch keine
antwort gehört wie wollen sie es ändern
indem wir die ostdeutschen sehr wohl mut
machen da diese wie wollen sie mut
machen indem wir ihnen ganz klar sagen
dass sie für diese position genauso
geeignet sind wie zum beispiel
westdeutscher ganz einfach und dass sie
diese auch diese herausforderung
annehmen sollen und das machen sie auch
es wird auch mehr als als ganze
zuschauer post die wir glaube ich jetzt
kriegen zu diesem thema leiten wir haben
sie weiter weil ich glaube dass es ein
bisschen schlich gedacht zu sagen wir
machen den menschen mut doch schon alle
da haben sie eine kurzumfrage jährigen
fragen wir kurz bei hectronic danach hat
hob aller ihnen jetzt gerade mut gemacht
den brauchte ich nicht den mut zuspruch
aber es verbindet sich was die beiden
sagten es ist dieses seilschaft denken
so sage ich das jetzt ist meine meinung
und die quotenregelung gibt den anderen
überhaupt erst mal die chance in diese
seilschaften einzudringen das ist es und
deswegen brauchen wir die quotenregelung
damit die chance überhaupt da ist sonst
halt mir nämlich zusammen selbst das
albertinum in dresden hat auf einmal
eine ja bestimmt fähiger leiterin aus
dem westen deutschlands
viele jahre konnten dass die
ostdeutschen jetzt können sie es nicht
mehr um ein aus dem westen
ja ich will nicht wissen wo diese wege
lang gehen das zauberwort heißt
transparenz wer entscheidet an welcher
stelle auf welcher grundlage und das
bleibt uns kleinen verborgen wir kriegen
immer nur das ergebnis wer da irgendwas
macht das r frage überhaupt nicht und
das ist das was auf respekt hinauswirft
[Musik]